today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza you
know you you you know you want pizza
right yeah so why have anything other
than gray block imagine having it in
your mouth boy
yeah 18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to
the beach great block pizza get that
hitter today's guest is a man that I met
at the gun store and I went in there
recently I'm gonna be very honest with
you and I didn't know what I was doing
but I did know that I wanted to get a
gun and and this man had so much
information and just knew so much in
that you know in that realm in the
bullet tree and he's also a gunsmith
he's an outdoorsman and he is a bonafide
gun man my new friend Niko furlong
[Music]
tell me I'll [ __ ] drink your blood
Sonique oh yeah I appreciate coming in
today man and you know because you sold
me two guns recently I did yeah you know
yeah that's and I was just thinking
about it whenever I was at the gun store
and what guns store do you work at
Turner's outdoorsman Rana we're on a
hop-on Boulevard North Torrance and they
got everything in there everything we
got handguns revolvers rifles shotguns
for all your needs and you need and I
noticed you have they have they have
everything if you want to be a murderer
if you want to be a fisherman if you
want to they have they have the full
spectrum you know you can you can go out
like North Hollywood you know the North
Hollywood shootout you can do just like
that you can you can shoot deer you know
what I mean
you could you can put your dog down
whatever you're into yeah you guys even
you guys can do all of that yeah we had
a guy bus actually that when I was
growing up that would put people's he
was kind of the guy if you had to put
your dog down really yeah you just call
him up oh you would call him or you just
go knock yeah what do you expect
compensation for that or you just do it
no he would just do it I just liked it
yeah well no he was just the kind of guy
he had done it enough I think a lot of
people are scared you know I don't want
to put my dog down I don't know how to
do it what if I shoot him in the wrong
place you know what if I [ __ ] or what
if some people would try to strangle
their dog or psycho King kid I can't get
him to go down my brother my brother put
our dog now really yeah he didn't mean
to what he did it on accident kind of my
dog was sick I don't swallow you know oh
yeah and he was old and getting sick dr.
Rizvi will put that [ __ ] thing down
oh yeah yeah I mean you can you can drop
a biscuit on the floor you'll hit him in
the head he's like Reginald any man back
there just yeah just like that yeah but
uh now he was like he was sick you know
and any little chihuahua so he wants to
sleep in the bed he goes under the
covers you know I think he was too weak
and he's sleeping with my with my
brother in his bed I don't think he
could get out I think he suffocated man
well Jesus Christ yeah my brother was
not happy yeah it's almost reminds me of
that movie um I'm trying to think of
that movie twins maybe you seen that
movie
before your time I think you bring up
that when something twins yeah um yeah
with Arnold Schwarzenegger though but uh
I think so
who was in it only once we need a video
insert neuron source in here I think
when I was born here with the governor
yeah it was before that he was with his
brother yeah damn man but yeah do you
sleep with your brother bro so anything
could die you know it's yeah yeah well
you thought you know the hairy Italian
guy you know yeah death under there yeah
one of the reasons I wanted to talk to
you is just because of like I ended up
buying some guns you know yeah entered
and I didn't I didn't know if I even
wanted any guns but once the pandemic
hit once the core of it came in I was
like I think I need to get some guns
yeah and and so I came over there to you
guys and uh and yeah just smile the
whole experience like what does the
experience been for you like working at
a gun store what what has it been like
since this pandemic hit what I mean it's
completely unprecedented what's going on
I worked there with a lot of guys have
been working in the firearms industry
for a long time real experienced guys
you know and they've been selling guns
for longer than I've been a lot oh dang
and wait wait oh yeah and they tell me
the same thing man they told me it's
unprecedented the month of March had
more background checks done than any
other month in the history of the United
States this is March of 2020 when the
first kind of panic started going on we
had over you know nearly 200 people
outside the store waiting to get in
before we open four to five our lines
just for service because we had we were
just full of people and and if you know
you know if you're around la you know
there's not that many gun stores there's
a few a handful just around especially
West LA and where we are you know kind
of like in the epicenter of a bunch of
different neighborhoods so we're by
Torrance my Hatton Beach Hawthorne you
know on the way to Gardena so we're kind
of like in that in right and right in
the middle of all that right so kind of
what kind of white getting Mexican II oh
it's I'm gonna be honest man it's mostly
Latino yeah mostly oak Lauren tells
mostly Latino but you get I mean I'm
always surprised when I started working
there the diversity of people purchasing
firearms it's all types and so when you
say like
kalsa how soon after kind of the
pandemic hit or after like did you
notice there was a certain thing that
brought people and it's like oh now we
gotta go get the guns like now a hundred
percent the vast majority of people in
there buying guns as a recent have been
brand new gun buyers never never bought
a gun in their life never even expected
to buy guns that's for a lot of them and
it was the first time and I was talking
to a lot of my co-workers was the first
time that people really started talking
about openly in the store buying these
guns and using them in the defense of
their property from people willing to
take it from them well a lot of people
were like oh hey I want you know I want
to get a tactical shotgun it's like oh
if you ever ask them well what do you
plan on doing with oh you know I just
you not the range I like it and you know
it's a good thing for home defense okay
granted as a common but now it's like oh
I need to get this because what if
someone breaks in and they're trying to
take my stuff and or they were just
going off about it they're talking about
you know their it kind of reminded them
of the rights in LA 92 some of the
old-timers talk about the Watts Riots
back and I believe the 70s yeah yes
specially living in this area that's
another thing I thought about I was like
well I live in an area that has a
history of unrest you know if civil
unrest if things get you know if things
get squirreled out really so yeah cuz
that's it cuz it's funny cuz I was even
thinking to myself like why am i buying
a gun you know what am i I mean I think
I'd always kind of wanted to get a gun
but I'd never acted on it and then
suddenly it was like okay I'm going to
get this gun yeah and and I think it was
just yeah I'm gonna be able to take care
of myself I want to be able to like if
things get real heated you know and
somebody's coming over somebody's
stealing diapers from me or stealing
water or stealing whatever you know like
they come for that teepee brother they
won't yeah they're coming for your
collared shirt yeah people all right I
guess it's funny because of my fur I
think my first instinct would be if
somebody like really needed help would
be to help them right but then if
somebody's coming in with the intent not
looking for help right they're there for
your stuff yeah they're for your life
man yeah what were some of the have you
gotten some wild questions from people
during the oh my god you have no idea
man all types I mean you get you guys
you get all types of weirdos in there
man I remember one dude was coming in he
was like an older white guy and he was
coming in he was
like he was like I'm looking for 4570
lever-action rifle and 45 seventies it
used to be the standard military
cartridge for the u.s. pretty much right
after the Civil War
hmm just pretty much until right before
World War one and it's a very powerful
large big bore cartridge they use it for
buffalo hunting stuff like that it's
just a very powerful cartridge
and-and-and the jail and the gentleman
was talking to it like oh yeah why like
why you looking for something like that
you know and he was like well I read
that this is a good gun for a riot I was
like mmm what does that mean what like a
good gun for riot like what're you gonna
do with it Yeah right and he's just like
oh you know like it's a heavy bullet so
he'll just little just sail through
crowds I'll fight I'll fight goddamn
alright like it's a good riot cartridge
then everybody get to the front of the
line oh yeah hell yeah man and all types
I mean a lot of people looking for
really cheap guns yeah I need some one
or two hundred dollars it was like dude
like I'm gonna sell you a knife man I
can't like there's not too many guns
yeah let me tell you a fast knife you
can throw it man yeah there's your range
and so is but you got a lot of new users
in for the first time yeah and we're so
what's what's a gun that you you usually
recommend for those types of people uh
if they're looking for I gotta ask them
we're looking for a rifle you're looking
for a shotgun looking for a handgun most
people can at least answer though that
question like what out of those three
major categories can are you looking for
right and and if they're looking for a
handgun I recommend just most polymer
frame striker fired pistols really easy
to use like a Glock for an example
Springfield XDS because we're limited on
what we can get here in California Smith
& Wesson
you know shields Smith & Wesson SD nines
that kind of thing those guns are really
popular for new gun buyers because
they're really really simple to use and
and they're just effective they just do
the job and when you say that so
California has like different laws like
would they have different we can't get
certain types of guns here you mean or
we can oh yeah well okay well with long
guns rifles and shotguns you're not
really limited on the exact specific
guns you can get they have to be
California compliant which kinds they
have to have a list of features that are
not on the gun
it's really stupid and convoluted and
then for for handguns there's like
there's something called a California
handgun roster where there's an actual
list of designated models that you can
buy here in California what that pretty
much entails as far as I understand it
is that they pre-much need to pay a lot
of money and pass all these safety
requirements to get on the roster okay
and then for semi-automatic handguns
like one of the guns that you purchase a
semi-automatic handgun they pretty much
need to be made after the year 2013 not
the actual make but the design of the
gun needs to be from 2013 or before that
the reason for that is the California
pretty much died believe it was
Department of Justice they dictated that
if you're gonna bring a new gun on the
roster a new semi-automatic handgun on
the roster it needs to have micro
stamping technology okay that was I
believe those are the words they used
okay Micro stamping technology would
wouldn't would entail where if you fired
the bullet it would leave an imprint on
the bullet that would be able to track
the gun specifically to that serial
number right okay that technology does
not exist but we would know what you see
this often like you see a lot of times
on like crime shows and stuff where
people use a bullet and you can trace it
back to a gun yeah what that would
pretty much entail is based on the way
the firing pin hits the primer of the
cartridge they can tell what kind of gun
it is was it a revolver and maybe they
could even tell what specific what
specific actual firearm it is oh that
was a I'm basing it on the extraction
pattern as well oh that was that was a
Glock 17 for an example or not even a 17
they can show oh it's a Glock
9-millimeter okay that's just one thing
they can tell from it but with
microstamping technology they pretty
much are saying that they can track
using the imprint from the firing pin
they can track the actual guns serial
number directly to you which on CSI it's
a fantasy that's not true look that up
do you on net microstamping is a process
in which a gun imprints a unique
microscopic code onto the ammunition it
fires the goal is to enable detectives
to collect shell casings at a crime
scene enter the code in a debit database
and quickly track the firearm to its
owner the problem is the technology is
unreliable and expensive each time a gun
is fired it wears slightly leaving a
micro stamp unreadable
after a short period of normal use
almost like a regular like a regular
stamp if you run out of like I guess the
ability maybe to like one of those ink
pads or something then you're done huh
and so I guess they're trying to make so
this seemed like an early this seems
like a plan
that would make great sense but they
just do not have the technology for it
yet right and and nor is it practical in
the sense of it actually mitigating
crime well yeah I mean if you do have
micros and big technology you could tell
which firearms specifically it was right
however there are certain requirements
that consider something a firearm in the
United States okay it and it's typically
the frame also the receiver of a gun
right so if you have a Glock pistol
right which is a very standard pistol
just the plastic frame is the only part
on the gun that actually has a serial
number everything else is just it's just
a metal part you can order it all online
right I can buy a Glock by a firing pin
online for ten dollars mmm replace the
firing pin and it would have a different
micro stamp I see what you're saying
it's very easy to guy differently and
what's to stop someone from just
grounding it off right it would do
nothing so this is a bit so this is
something that theoretically would be
great but in reality doesn't it's not
really very practical exactly and this
is a law now that you had to have that
you have to have this yeah so new new
handguns from manufacturers to be sold
in California semi-automatic handguns
need to have micro stamping technology
for them to be approved on the roster
okay and the one that I've bought is
that is if a gun that does not have
Michael Stanback technology because it
was being made and sold in California
before the year 2013 oh I see so his
grandfather didn't kind of kind of I
mean the gun that you have is brand-new
right I it no one used it or anything
it's just that that specific model was
allowed because they were making and
selling that model he to California
there was they were selling the model
here in California before the year 2013
so of the new like gun owners you're
seeing like people that have come to the
shop recently who are they like where do
they look like what are they I mean you
said it was a lot of Latino stout their
mom is it a lot of gangsters there's a
lot of females what is it you know well
at our all-time fan at our shop we get
we get a lot of gangsters gangsters of
all kinds I mean I've seen like dudes
that are borderline like white
nationalist
so yeah straight up like straight up
show low it got all excited yeah just
straight like just black gangsters yeah
Bloods crib that kind of stuff and and
yeah they don't I mean a lot of times
they don't even hide it like I what
about Jews do you see any Jews in there
a few not too many I feel like I feel
like I don't know I feel like a lot of
Jewish supremacists now like you devout
Judaism only type of [ __ ] yeah
scientists you know yeah right I feel
like I feel like they have their own way
of getting guns we sell Jewish guns got
some like stuff from Israel there which
is kind of cool Wow yeah Israel makes a
lot of weapons yeah it's a weapon belt
over there hell yeah hell yeah to
technology and weapons man yeah well
they're surrounded by their enemy if you
know yeah it's a hot area it's a good
area to have a weapon yeah hell yeah so
so so go ahead you're seeing you've seen
a lot of Latinas you've seen a lot again
is that a lot of gangbangers it is a lot
of step now I'm not almost not a lot you
get if you get that occasionally it's
just a lot of just really random people
man whether it's like people my age you
know just first-time gun buyers 21 years
old single women some women with kids
anything fears about the pan debt like
about the okay 100% they're there
they're there telling telling us like I
don't know what to get I don't know
anything about guns I don't even really
want to know anything about guns I just
want to get one that was me really yeah
kind of I mean I had yeah I knew I
wanted a handgun I'll look through right
some guns and kind of picked out the one
that I wanted exactly but I don't think
you were there entirely out of out of
fear man they were a lot people were
there really just like looking around
and they just kind of they just kind of
were freaking me out to be honest with
you know and is there an element where
you have to like if somebody's choose
you you determined that they have too
much fear is that can you still have to
sell them a gun I wouldn't say I have to
but there's a scary person to sell a gun
to you know I'm saying like yeah if I'm
coming from a place of like yeah just
complete fear then I could I could make
some poor choices you know a hundred
percent you don't want to [ __ ] shoot
a guy and he just had the mail yeah I
know for sure but that's that that's
where it gets tricky because you also
don't want to deprive someone of their
second Amendment right especially when
there's a limited amount of gun stores
and it's hard for them to get in I mean
a lot of people were waiting for five
hours for service yeah and they want to
get a gun and despite the reasons I mean
I
fear that's not necessarily a reason
where I can take away their
constitutional right that's what I see
right so yeah so there's no so there's
nothing in it like where you make any
sort of like psychological like mental
health evaluation of them we have the
freedom to okay we can and like another
thing like by requirement if you smell
like marijuana I can't serve you Wow
liddie and I've had a to like I mean man
I have some stories of these gangsters
that come in all the time man or just
anyone any people it's not like weed but
just like usually people that walk into
a gun some real [ __ ] cholos I mean
they sayin that they fit in there
infinity you know and they're smoking up
back with ya and they're like they're in
the parking lot and the road right now
let's go buy guns now freak yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] and do they a lot of
times thinkin able to get it day of Oh
almost people in not most but a lot of
people were getting upset at us because
they were like it's a 10-day waiting
period in California so if you start the
background check that day right then ten
days from now you can come pick it up
right right that's what I'm going
through right now
I just got extended to it just got a as
of recent they've been extended a little
bit the DOJ pretty much sent out a
notification to us that they're
completely backed up on background
checks going through so even after the
10-day waiting period the background
check might not have cleared yet so
we've had I mean this weekend probably
over 40 people come pick up their guns
and we had to deny them that access to
pick up their firearm even if it's after
their 10-day waiting period you just due
to the fact that they cannot the DOJ has
not cleared their their background check
it Wow yeah it's just pending and I
checked it for you your pickup date with
yesterday yeah you're going through the
same thing if you came in yesterday to
get your firearms which it would have
been after the 10-day waiting period you
would not have been able to and now has
that ever happened in your line like in
your time of work no one I talked to
there has ever seen that ever and so
what do you attribute that to just the
sheer amount of people that are buying
guns in the United States and California
it may be it's good at least it's like
okay we have to run some sort of a
background check we're not just
filtering all these people through yeah
yeah I mean especially in California man
that that background check process is
California and there's other states to
do backgrounds there's a national
background check system right when you
fill out paperwork and that's what you
did right and that Nash
background check system doesn't
necessarily mean a 10-day waiting period
there's a lot of other states where you
can buy a day off and take it home yeah
California is one of one of the only and
not one of the only but there's a few
states that have a waiting period day of
you can buy oh yeah yeah I mean Arizona
Utah you go buy it they uh fill out the
paperwork take it home dude Arizona you
know that they take a driver's license
picture when you're like 19 years old
and then you have to get it done again
for 50 years [ __ ] imagine yeah guys
like an old man man he look at me see
your ID it doesn't even look like him
and like his kids look at the grandkids
man hey there are cool cats and kittens
caryl basking here from Big Cat Rescue
oh look did Carol bask and feed her
husband to los Tigres papa huh did she
do it [ __ ] yeah she did we don't know
but what we do know is every man should
trim his balls I want you to take a
second and look down get your pants off
or pretend your pants are off and look
down when was the last time you shaved
your junk you running around here with
that dirty fan trunk out in front of you
you're trying to feed your wiener
peanuts and drink water through your
dick you're out of your mind it's been a
while since you clean your junk bucko
that's why our sponsors manscaped are
dedicated to making sure your jungle
gets tamed that's right I've often
looked at my penis and been like oh I
can do better than this okay and that's
some time if you can't grow more dick or
anything you got to get your hair better
cut your hair to make your dick look
better and you can do that now with man
escapes redesigned electric trimmer the
manscaped engineering team has their
third generation trimmer called the lawn
mower 3.0 and this thing has skin-safe
technology you cannot cut your penis or
balls open that's all we need to say
okay look when I was growing up you had
to remember using a gas powered trimmer
Ramon wiener
and you know how that ended r.i.p my
buddy they also make charging the
lawnmower super easy with its
intelligently designed USB convenient
charging dock that's right you can be
doing work charge your d trimmer right
there on the computer bang get in the
shower and cut your dick up you know
what I mean
they got that USB charger dock you can
do your work and then do your junk and
if you're a true tiger king fan you can
now safely make Tiger king stripes and
your pubes get 20% off in free shipping
with the code th EO at manscaped
dot-com I know you listen to this every
week you're like I've heard this ad
before then use the ad quit just
listening to it you don't quit do
yourself a favor and get the right stuff
to take care of your damn penis and nuts
you idiot that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscaped calm and use code
th e Oh make sure to tame your jungle I
hate to interrupt this episode but as
folks adapt and that is a word to this
challenging new world we are all going
to be buying more items online than ever
before so if you're an e-commerce seller
are you ready to meet the demands of our
new delivery culture well you can be
with ship station that's right ship
station when you're selling online
getting a lot of orders getting them out
fast can be tough oh okay I can barely
do it well how do you keep track of who
gets what oh this is for Anthony and
this is for Tanya and more which ship
carrier should you use FedEx UPS Amazon
Fulfillment googoo are you getting the
best rates don't think about all that
let ship station dot-com do it for you
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your
product to happy customers shipstation
makes it easy look if you're selling
stuff if you're getting rid of things if
you're if you're moving inventory take
the pressure off your neck and use
shipstation it works with all the major
carriers UPS FedEx UPS Amazon
Fulfillment you can compare and choose
the best shipping solution for you and
your customer they even offer big
discounts on shipping costs now any
regular business can access the same
shipping discounts that are usually
reserved for large fortune 500 companies
and right now this past weekend
listeners can try shipstation
come on try it for free it's free to try
for 60 days when you use the offer code
Theo
th e o make sure your business is ready
to meet the demands of delivery culture
support this past weekend get started at
ship station comm just click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
that's shipstation dot-com then enter
code Theo ship station dot-com make ship
happen but that seems wow because if you
like do you prefer that there is a that
there's a waiting period it seemed like
there needs there definitely should be a
because what if I'm just pissed about
something right what if I am [ __ ]
high what if I'm coked up what if I'm
this or that no that's all on the tea or
tea and I want to go [ __ ] you know
that's gonna sleep and shoot the devil
you know does California have one of the
longest ones is 10-day when I believe
10-day is a long one
yeah I believe we do have a long before
nine hundred percent on that but I'm 99
percent sure yeah and it's a pretty
assistive pretty obviously it's a
California's a pretty liberal state you
know or me certainly the Los Angeles
area is and I was like really shocked or
not when when it was hard to get in over
at you guys in spice you know there was
just such it was like a waiting period
to get in you know it's just and then
they had just made a law or passed a
some sort of ruling that you guys
weren't even to be allowed to sell guns
anymore yeah the the governor Gavin
Newsom yeah extremely anti-gun and the
sheriff of Los Angeles County
at one point both declared that that gun
stores should be closed down and they're
not essential that's because they were
pretty much seeing
the giant rush on gun stores however I
believe they were flooded with a bunch
of lawsuits like constitutional lawsuits
I owe you well that's you know trumping
our Second Amendment right so then they
actually general just pulled off on it
so in some counties they have yeah stop
them I know art I know the Turner's
location in Oxnard they were they were
shut down by the by the police there
because by the by the sheriff there
because of their orders for their County
but LA County is not one of those
counties does it does it worry you like
that there's gonna be a lot more guns
like flooding like even just driving
around anything like aw [ __ ] now there's
a lot more [ __ ] with guns like do
you think about that at all yeah I mean
I thought I've thought about it not much
I can do about it man it that's always
been that's always been a part of
American life man there's always been
firearms yeah they've always been here
well the big bang theory if you think
about that I mean America started with a
you know I mean oh the world started
with okay yeah [ __ ] somebody setting
it off you know a hundred percent yeah
it would have been God just shooting yes
turning the universe man yeah dude
somebody just yeah the pan hitting the
frickin firing pin in the primer there
it is phone after that man just chaos
you can't be shocked if somebody else
wants to do it no I don't know I can
somebody the most a big bang is somebody
[ __ ] running oh yeah and if you ever
shot a gun man I mean a lot of people
that are there anti-gun I've never fired
a weapon
yeah it's exhilarating it's a lot of fun
it captures it captures your kind of a
kind of visceral need for destruction in
a way well I've said that before and uh
you know I had a buddy who said that he
killed he killed someone
yeah and he said that he said it was he
said it was awesome
oh yeah and I'm not saying I don't
condone what he said oh yeah and I'm not
saying he should have done it or any
[ __ ] like that but he did I trust some
of his beliefs you know it's not easy
but I trust some of his I trust his own
evaluation of what you heard oh yeah I
got a lot of buddies in the military man
and and they haven't seen any combat yet
and they're they're just training and
you know they're all a lot of them are
infantrymen and they're getting into it
you know but they tell me about it
they're my age and all they want to do
go fight all they want to do is go fight
and I mean I can't say I don't
understand it it's a people you know
people my age young men for the history
of the human race men have been wanting
to go to war yeah yeah there's something
about I was talking about this last week
on the podcast if there's something
about us that has like an other thing of
like anarchy that I I noticed like this
pandemic starts to like it starts to
light that fuse a little bit oh yeah
like what if we all got to go back to
the Wild West days you know like what if
you know suddenly like the services in
society that we're in it starts to break
down yeah I think there are some people
who not only would like to have that a
little bit of that grant theft auto type
of lifestyle but then also some people
who want to just be prepared for it yeah
like you don't want to show up you know
you don't want to show up really late to
just saving yourself you know I'm being
prepared because once it once once [ __ ]
hits the fan you not gonna be able to
get a gun there won't be gun stores I
hope you don't say I'm one like if
things get really bad like things aren't
gonna be open it's not gonna be
available I'm not gonna be able to go to
your neighbor like hey give me a gun
they're like nah yeah yeah I'm gonna
shoot you so I can run the building yeah
I mean that's why I'm a whole family
live in one block you know what I mean
so I guess I'm pretty sad it's a lot of
firepower right there you know fence
really located yeah but uh but not mine
yeah 100% I mean you have you have a lot
of people that kind of have that hunger
for for chaos you know it's just it's
just the way it is when you let me look
at the u.s. today it's so everything I
mean it's so complicated our lives it's
all social media and and oh going to
work on time and and all that and I feel
like people are getting kind of sick of
it eventually they just kind of want to
they kind of just want that chaos to
boil over man it just gives them a
little bit time and relief yeah yes oh
yeah a lot of human beings that once are
that wants some sort of chaos or and
then if they don't at least once to be
prepared for it at least recognizes that
it's in other people I mean even if you
look back in the Bible man which is you
know I mean it's a hit-or-miss book but
if you like Cain and Abel they had four
people in the world and one of them
killed the other one you know what I'm
saying yeah
Eve Cain Abel [ __ ] Abel killed Cain I
think are one of them but do did that
funny when you think about that there's
four people four people do you think you
would be excited there's finally four of
us and one of them's like now [ __ ] it
[ __ ] in your boy right here okay you
like Abel murdered Cain
yeah bro Abel [ __ ] murdered Cain dawg
so that's what you gonna be like hey bro
I read it wrong you had it right the
first time a murder yes sir yeah that's
what I thought because yes we Cain I
remember seeing those bumper stickers
growing up okay yeah like if your
brother gets out of line yes we can okay
but so yeah I just think there's
inherently there's something minutes
that makes us want to act out and so
when this starts [ __ ] starts to happen
you get people and lights that fuse it
lights that limbic part of their brain
that's like how am I gonna take care of
myself
yeah how am I going to protect my family
death definitely man and if you think
about it like what time in history in
the US captures people imagination more
than anything else is the Wild West yeah
you know I mean a you're in the saloon
someone looks at your girl you shoot him
yeah yeah I mean some of this agree that
you lost a poker game shoot him yeah you
know you see someone out there take your
stuff kill a horse you know I mean well
that's see the third part I don't like
as much the first two I could definitely
I would sit on a trial for right a third
one I'd be like a horse the third one
I'm like my name is signing up for this
guy's guilty what if you're hungry man
[ __ ] well if you're hungry man I think
if you're real hungry dude yeah look
I've told you before I need a neighbor
ID'd somebody I'm not afraid not for
sure
I've eaten rare [ __ ] I'll have a little
more yeah that's how I'm not afraid to
go down that you know that uh that kind
of you know palette path you know I'm
not afraid to [ __ ] eat somebody you
almost say been the young Viet yeah
almost ate a bit into a [ __ ]
Vietnamese guy today him Best Buy and
that was just when I was a fasting right
yeah that was for starvation this is
your talk about real starvation brother
yeah because you got to think if [ __ ]
goes weird you're in an apartment
building right immediately it's like
okay yeah things are gonna get weird
quick like if society started to break
down right nobody's been picking up
trash no so you have no trash pickup
right so everything is going to start to
stink everything's nobody's uh
if who knows have clean water plants and
that sort of stuff is starting to work
do you
fresh water do you have water at home so
uh people are gonna be on edge on edge
oh yeah so suddenly like [ __ ] your
apartment building is gonna start to
become like a little bit of I don't
think everything like a let's be on the
same team and team up together no no
it's definitely not man I mean I was
just uh I just came back from the
Philippines man and over there you can
see how people are they're they're
really community oriented everyone kind
of sees each other like a big family hmm
that's the way I felt when I was over
there but over here man it's it's
dog-eat-dog you know that's how I feel I
feel like you'll have a lot of people
that are trying to like work together
but you know Americans can get be
selfish you know they're looking out for
themselves especially in a city I think
in a city you're dealing with that like
I think if once I got out to like a more
of a rural environment or something you
have a bit of land you have some space
where you can see okay if there's people
out on the Ponderosa what's going on you
have animals that are around that you
could trust to go out and get a little
bit of light Intel yeah show back up at
the house you know what I'm saying
though like you have real Recon cow yeah
yeah I get to you have a [ __ ] cow
that could wreak on out there and then
shake that bale of shit's [ __ ]
getting wiry
just put it GoPro on them man let me
come back you watch it oh I knew those
[ __ ] were out there man I
goddamn it
if I don't saying you can send a little
Shepherd you know you could say well
German Shepherd out there or a shepherd
or anything you could do whatever you
want man I'm just yeah it's uh but I
don't think I want to be the guy sitting
on my porch without a weapon yeah I mean
you definitely want to be the guy that's
unarmed in that situation right I mean
without a weapon here and I mean I don't
think anything's gonna get that bad
hopefully not I mean things are looking
better already
right but agree agree if [ __ ] goes down
the drain you do not want to be the guy
that's unarmed it's like it's like being
and it's like being in prison and you're
not like when in one of those like
racial gangs it yeah I mean it's like
showing up in prison without a butt hole
later no yeah yeah it's like I mean what
are you offering then yeah if you don't
gotta butter what are you doing right
well it's like how are we gonna win
everybody else you don't really think I
had a butthole
cuz you're not gonna [ __ ] last very
long yeah what I'm sayin do you guys
have weapons Nick Jionni you guys have
weapons or no I just bought a gun but my
older brother has a gun my dad has like
six guns so but your dad doesn't live
here does he no so okay so that's out of
the pictures you get one gun with your
brother but I bought a shotgun and I
a 9-millimeter okay there it is yet I
have no guns but I want to but it sounds
like a hassle I know it's not that big
of a deal you just have to go twice but
yeah I don't know yeah no brother we got
our Asian word were yeah yeah we got you
man
and then I wonder if it like it but at a
certain point but they do you worried
that they would shut down the gun stores
yeah I'm not too worried about that you
know um I'm ready to rock and roll so
have you had um have you had people come
to buy a weapon and you're like and you
knew yeah that they were gonna use it
for a crime oh yeah I got a I got a few
good stories like that you know like
sometimes you get those precarious
characters man you know oh yeah and they
come in like hey man I'm looking for I'm
looking for a like a pocket 9-millimeter
I'm like okay and we do sell small you
know concealable handguns and they're
like okay yeah let me see that and then
they don't wanna know about the specs
they don't give a [ __ ] about it they
don't care about anything about the gun
they just like oh yeah let me see that
and they kind of hold it and then
they're like they just put it in their
pocket I'm just like and I'm just like
I'm like a man like can you're not put
in your pocket he's just like hey I'm
just seeing like if it fits I'm like
okay and then like I saw dude one time
he put in his pocket and he pulls it out
and draws it like I'm a table right at
my chest
yeah usually like that and I'm like and
I'm just like all right I mean we got
guns pointing out if all day over there
I pointed at you don't accident a couple
times that's okay man I'd listen I've
had I mean we have time for people
pointing shotguns 12-gauge shotguns
right there i level yeah I got the
counter and I'm like call me the n-word
you're like oh when you work at a
banking you're like uh-oh dude man I
when I was like 18 I worked at Big Five
you know and I was there and we sell BB
guns at Big Five BB handguns and it look
real you know and I remember the I
remember these two brothers came in and
they came in there and they're looking
and they're you know they smell like
weed and they're like oh yeah I'm
looking for that handgun right there
that [ __ ] look real I'm like okay so
I'll show it to him and they're that
he's just looking at he's like yeah man
this will do the job and I'm just like
oh you guys like what are you guys doing
with it and he just like oh nothing you
know and then like I said joke he points
it at his friend his head he yells out a
mic in the store everyone turns around
looks he's like he's like rub me them
shoes [ __ ] and he's like
screaming at his friend I was like oh
[ __ ] man like these guys are like -
she's role-playing oh yeah yeah but
and they're like oh yeah that's the work
if they bought it it was like 90 bucks
you know damn fake hangar so yeah those
people so that people coming in if you
had somebody come in and you knew
they've you ever had somebody
straight-up tell you like don't sell me
a gun cuz I'm gonna kill somebody
no but I mean we you know we have to ask
those questions like I asked you Theo
like hey man you ever can you know I
there's four questions that you have to
ask and then you have the whole list you
know and when they're filling out the
paperwork and then asking if you're a
convicted felon they're like hmm
and like I see people like struggle on
it they're like uh what if I was
convicted but it wasn't like a violent
felony and I'm just like yeah I can't do
that I just kind of take the paper like
am i a felony sorry have you been
convicted of felony unless it's been
completely like acquitted you know this
you've been completely like found not
guilty of the crime and haven't been
convicted then if you even if you're a
convicted felon we can't sell your gun
first you'll ever fluoresce your life
rescue like yeah
can I do it yeah the test was pretty
tricky I remember um can you bring up
that test name I could not find it okay
California FSC test firearm safety
certificate how many did you get wrong
for you do you remember I think I got
three wrong yeah yeah you got he got
three wrong yeah yeah
27 out of 30 yeah it took me longer than
most people to take the test I feel like
it took you it took you a while man but
you're making jokes while you're doing
it too man I remember everyone was
laughing when you were taking the test
because you were tail you're saying some
funny [ __ ] well it's trying to sneakily
get information out of people too I was
trying to start a little conversation
and see if somebody would drop a little
hint of it of Intel because some of the
questions were a little bit tough I felt
like it took me about 40 minutes to take
it
that's probably looked like a study
guide you can take like a practice test
like California FSC practice test and
they'll have some of the questions on
there it's funny because people get the
same ones wrong all the time it's always
the same questions they get wrong yeah
it was uh some of this stuff for me the
age at which you can buy a firearm yeah
yeah it's 21 for longer than handguns in
California used to be 18 for long guns
21 for handguns they change that they
change that I believe 2019 January 1st
2019 and here's a question right here is
it legal to store a loaded firearm in
the premises where children have access
to no it's not yeah let's let's see I
have Theo take
oh yeah for sure definitely what is not
a part of a cartridge or a shotgun shell
I'm gonna go with the choke what types
of sight do the handgun shooters use
that's a dumb question
yeah really dumb question I would say a
all of the above I mean D a sale or
transfer of a firearm between two
private parties must be completed
through a licensed firearms dealer only
if the buyer and seller do not
personally know each other that is false
it must be completed between a licensed
dealer no matter what in fact that's the
one I got wrong yeah I didn't know that
that's that's the one most people get
wrong during the FSC so if you so if I
want to sell a friend a gun I want to
sell gianni or Nick a gun I have to go
through a licensed dealer come by to us
or any other gun store tell me one do a
private party transfer they're gonna
charge you a small fee we can which get
all both you guys of information the gun
is then legally transferred over to the
person that you're selling it to the
money doesn't go through us or anything
like that we just collect our small feet
money's all handled outside of the store
within 10 days the buyer can come pick
it up and that's it just like a normal
process we just hold onto the gun for 10
days they come pick it up and if I sell
it to Johnny just without going through
a licensed dealer then felony this
felony Wow you know yeah it's just in
California is that everywhere some
states do not have they don't day with
no need for a background check for
private party so I believe Texas is one
of those states I mean you'll have like
videos of people buying guns who like I
McDonald's bathroom you know I mean hey
let's meet up and then there's some
they're selling a goddamn Glock 19 who's
producing that why can't we do that name
yeah probably sicker in them generally
it is legal to carry a concealed firearm
in public under which of the following
circumstances you're an experienced gun
Handler and know all the safety rules
you were honorably discharged from the
military you are in an unsafe area is
legal to carry a firearm public under
which of the fine services uh I'm on
guard I'm like I mean none of the above
no I'm in gardena bro I can carry a gun
man cool yeah no just joking man
yeah it's hard to get a concealed carry
license in California it's pretty
difficult
LA County nearly impossible unless you
know somebody right Wow yeah the first
cartridge loaded into a magazine presses
against the no idea I would go with
magazine spring but I have no idea that
what follower that one the follower yeah
the follower is a little piece of
plastic or metal that's in front of the
magazine spring that pushes up on the
cartridge that's a dumb question that's
not even on the real FS yeah sound of
the test yeah but these are some of the
questions that are on there a smokeless
loud or black powder that wasn't on
there no yeah I feel like it might be an
old version of the test or something but
some of the questions are on there but
yeah do you see any of these that are at
the actual test cuz I googled what you
yeah a few a few than we went through
are on the actual test the gun hand I
don't need these links he's saying oh
I'm not I'm not I'm not sure not sure I
actually like III owned about I owned
about more than 10 guns without ever
taking the FFC test because before I
mean you can you can buy guns here the
hunting license they just played with
the law a little bit now but like you
can buy you can buy long guns at 18
still now if you have a hunting license
so I was 18 I mean I got hunting license
and I was like twelve right but so when
I turned 18
with my hunting license I was able to
buy a bunch of long guns so that's what
I did mmm so I never even took that test
until I actually started working there
Wow yeah no idea so that's just because
that's a new legislate new new law you
have to take that test that test also uh
when you're 21 you can buy a handgun
that's before and the hunting license
does not apply to handguns oh I see
weirdly enough but so I had to for me to
buy a handgun on how to take that FSC
test and then plus I I mean I've graded
20 of them before I ever took stuff do
you think that um do you think that you
could shoot somebody yeah yeah I think I
can yeah awesome man I mean I grew up
hunting man and that's where would you
shoot them where did I shoot somebody
yeah
what depends man be honest brother well
I'll be honest with you man if it's if I
if you're in a situation where you have
to if you have to pull out a firearm and
you're gonna use it on somebody you're
shooting to kill right you're not gonna
shoot him in the leg but if you're
shooting someone in the leg you're in a
situation where where you you have the
intention to injure them where you're
trying to MIT you're trying to stop one
of their behaviors by injury right in
especially in California
and most states when you're actually
gonna use a firearm on somebody and
you're not law enforcement you're
pulling out that gun that gun is coming
out because your life is currently like
you're to let your life will be taken if
you don't use this right or somebody in
your house or someone your family member
Harris that they are going to accept
that or somebody now you're exactly a
somebody in that house there's somebody
where you are is going to die or going
to be grievously injured if you do not
use this firearm so if you're using that
gun you're using it to put an immediate
end to the fight and you have videos all
types of videos that people getting shot
15 times and they're still doing what
they're doing because none of the shots
are lethal well they might be lethal
eventually but they're not immediately
debilitating yeah you got to turn the
lights off you're gonna shoot so you're
talking here or here
that's it that's that's where you would
shoot I'd rather shoot somebody in the
chest I think because I don't want to
shoot somebody in the face you know cuz
I look at them in their face like oh
yeah and then it's just the back ends
blown out yeah you don't want to see
that yeah and NAM do you do you um have
you ever seen anyone shoot somebody else
okay well not like I've never seen like
it like a okay technically yes but not
not in a way where it was like a real
lethal wound I've technically been shot
right many many times I go I go hunting
right I'm mostly hunt birds because a
Southern California is the biggest kind
of hunting season there is dove hunting
and if you're in these busy fields going
dove hunting there's people on the other
side of the field and they're shooting
doves and all those pellets are flying
in the air and they land on you like
what's up my dad shot me like pretty
close it stung like a [ __ ] but
yeah but it was a shotgun for shooting
tiny little bird shot
but I was a good you know 50 yards away
so what stung like a [ __ ] but
you know a man accidents happen
especially when you're you know whipping
birds flying around so assume your aim
and it's your [ __ ] sauna bet yeah you
know I kind of pissed them off that day
man yeah yeah so I was thinking he can't
just want to punish me a little bit I
was kind of the age we can't really
smack me around anymore
oh yeah he's just like I'm just like
he's just like oh I saw quail over there
that
I didn't see that [ __ ] coil but yeah
he gets you a jacket that has four
quails on the back of it yeah exactly
dude no orange on me man you see student
through the bush hell yeah dude yeah I
mean it sucks but if you if you go dove
hunting in a busy field you will get
shot with a shotgun yeah I promise you
you will I like that I don't have any
scars from it everybody technically
speaking yeah I've been hit with the
projectile from a firearm yes yeah do
you think that a lot of the people
you've been selling guns to in this
recent surge of gun sales has been
people that are more on the liberal side
of politics yeah I would say yeah
a lot of people that I talked to were
admittingly
and that's the thing man I'm not I'm not
big on that word liberal because in the
camp maybe that's not the right word
that's right just in the classical sense
liberal means like oh you believe in the
freedom of the individual right right
which would be pro-gun so I mean yeah I
mean like or far-left laughing yeah I
for sure for sure definitely a lot of
that a lot of people admittingly and you
can kind of just tell you know just by
the way they look and the way they act
or with a dress you can kind of figure
it out something with conservatives you
can kind of just point them out oh yeah
for sure but a lot of them admittingly
like oh I never thought I'd be buying a
gun I never thought I'd be every doing
something like this but here I am and
I'm there and a lot of them were up like
upset with themselves like a lot of
times like Oh first-time gun buy and I
was trying to make conversation because
we're doing paperwork you excited
they're like nope oh my oh why you here
man
and they're like I'm just like like I
don't even want a gun man but I feel
like I need one well that's what a lot
of people were saying a lot of people
think that it's interesting man cuz I
mean I think it's even like how I felt a
little bit like I feel like I've wanted
to kind of have one for a little bit
yeah this was definitely the this just
the fear of the uncertainty of what's
gonna go on or what could go on or the
camel's back huh yeah there it is yeah I
I totally understand i resignate with
that end I get it but that was enough
most people that were buying guns in
this big surge especially here in
California yeah new gun buyers
definitely first time first time
brand-new never shot a gun before how
long do you think so this 10 days been a
little long how long do you think it
this needs you know I mean you think
it'll be another ten days do you think
now they usually clear it up within 24
to 48 hours after the 10 days yeah but
people get impatient yeah
I had people like when the big rush yell
at me because they didn't know it was
the 10-day waiting period so they're
buying the gun they think they can take
it home the same day and I'll you know
I'll sell them the gun I go through the
whole paperwork and then I'll tell them
I oh yeah so here's your pickup date and
they're like what like like I need to
get the gun now I'm like yeah well okay
I can't do that man it's you know 10-day
waiting period in California ten days I
had people like there's not gonna be a
[ __ ] city in ten days man I need this
gun right now
really yeah oh yeah I heard a few people
kind of like a nose I can you watch ARCA
no I watched for a season yeah yeah it's
kind of one of those sewed up feel like
it's like good until you realize it's
not any [ __ ] good but in the second
season they're not to get a baby and
they try to get it it's like a 10-day
waiting period and the guys like no we
knew this maybe right now dude what
could it need a baby for an emergency
man [ __ ] it so is our yeah yeah some
[ __ ] you got a garden I need a baby
to guard my house it really kind of did
it really yeah it's kind of a part of a
weird trade-off for some [ __ ] oh yeah
I'll give you I'll give you baby if you
if you launder this money from you man
and I'll give you a million dollars but
give me your [ __ ] baby man I mean
yeah you basically just let yeah you
listed all the plots so you're buying a
tiger yeah he lists all the plots of the
season - um any other questions guys
some of you guys are thinking about are
there any people recently you're like
they shouldn't have a gun but you yeah
yeah I would say there's some people I
feel like not that they shouldn't have
one but I'm like they should really they
should really you know work on it if
they're gonna buy a gun you know like
they should really work on their skills
and and their capability of manipulating
the firearm before I they really get
this gun so I really highly I mean I
always tell them I highly recommend
training highly recommend when you get
the firearm keep the ammunition away
from it and just learn how the gun works
watch YouTube it's a huge resource for
firearms if you watch it somewhere on
the you know anything on the internet
like that you can learn a lot just from
there that's where I learned a lot of
the information I have about firearms I
learned through the internet or reading
books look out the gate you know I'm
coming at you 100/100 a lot of people
don't have that junk in the front trunk
when they want to they can't get
erection sometime you'll meet a friend
they can't get a wreck
you say what you doing buddy and they
won't tell you and that's because they
have shame about erection well this
episode is brought to you by blue chew
remember the days when you were always
ready to go when your dick was like a
just a big fat soft knife now you can
increase your performance and get extra
confidence in bed that's right listen up
blue chew dot-com that's blue like the
color blue blue to brings you the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
so don't be looking for these expensive
Gucci Louis all of this for your wiener
get that hard working get that babe
Henry that Blue Ox
Paul Bunyan you can take them any time
day or night even on a full stomach
you just had a half a pound of ravioli
so what throw that dick up or on top and
go go go to work since they're chewable
they work up to twice as fast as a pill
and you can lie to people tell you tell
them you having a gum or something see
I'm having a gum I'm having a Gobstopper
blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy and pretend you're
getting something else oh this is for my
cousin that ain't for you that ain't for
your cousin us for your wiener boy it
ships right to your door and discreet
packaging and right now you can support
this past weekend and stay erect at the
same time I mean who are we kidding
great idea we've got a special deal
visit blue chew comm and get your first
shipment for free when you use our
special promo code th e oh just pay the
five dollars shipping
that's right BL you e CH e w dot-com
promo code Theo to try it free blue chew
it's the better cheaper faster choice
and we thank them for sponsoring the
podcast and you go out and support them
thank you um they also have they have
you work at a gunsmithing place yeah
I've been there longer than
the gun shop okay and what is that when
you talk about gunsmithing what is that
so gunsmithing pretty much entails
repairs modifications custom builds I
mean it could be even little things
mounting a scope on to a rifle cleaning
guns so we do all of that I'm really
like I really like old guns military
surplus stuff so whenever we get old
guns in there that's like really my
thing but um like see war type [ __ ]
Civil War oh yeah well yeah not not too
much civil war I mean I like I like
Confederate stuff he's got a richer
history in terms of the firearm stuff
you know but you know and they had less
of a manufacturing base back in the
Civil War but a lot of a lot of World
War two pieces you know military surplus
stuff some World War one stuff which I
really like just even old just like old
hunting hunting rifles that are out of
production are just cool in general so
the two guns that I got one is a Beretta
it's a 9-millimeter right yeah it's a
Beretta m9 and it's you said it was like
the one of the most pop it was a issue
for law enforcement
until when 2018 a huge huge in law
enforcement for a long time still is it
was issue to the military so okay
US Army Marine Corps the Navy as well
Air Force pretty much the entire aspect
of the US military uses the yeah there
you go the Beretta m9 you know first
manufactured in Italy but the one you
guys made in the US hell yeah hell yeah
that's the best way to go off all-metal
all steel frame all steel slide single
double action yeah I mean it's it's
pretty much it's the Bruce Willis of
guns I like that man in silk double
action means that when you pull the
trigger hammers down it's a long heavy
trigger pull because that trigger
mechanically speaking has to pull that
hammer back and then drop it after the
the gun fires and the slide works back
and then forward again that's
automatically gonna push the hammer to
the rear so now it's just a short easy
light trigger pull just to drop that
hammer and that makes the gun a lot
easier to shoot yeah so uh and its
really your basic man's gun you get some
men that come in and their arms are
almost too weak to hold up a gun and
they still and you sell to sell them a
gun yeah I mean if they want if they
want a specific gun then they got it I
mean I remember I I had I had a little I
had a while ago I had a for the whole
rush I had a I had like a 85 year old
african-american woman and she would
with a cane you know just just frail and
she came and she's a young man I'm
looking for a double-barrel shotgun damn
I was like yeah okay we actually got
double-barrel shotgun so I'll put one in
her hands and she's like oh it's too
heavy you got something else like it
looks like yeah so I actually got her a
little Ruger like a LCR so it's a
polymer frame revolver mm super
lightweight she was able to handle it
but there's a lot of misconceptions
around guns you know but most people
basis of gun knowledge is gonna come
from the media it's gonna come from
movies video games TV shows and they are
notoriously bad at giving out accurate
information about firearms notoriously
bad have you had people come in and say
I want the gun that's in this game yeah
and you're crazy
yup kids that are just turning 21
they're like they're like they're like
hey what is what's that on the wall on
my OS a Chris vector and it's a sweet
decked out looking a little submachine
gun thing it's not an actual machine gun
it's a carbine semi-automatic because
we're not getting a yeah there you go
that Kriss vector yeah and and it's like
oh yeah man I used to I used to run that
thing in Call of Duty managed to run
that thing and want a more fair to all
types of yeah or just like I mean I had
a dude come in there didn't know
anything about guns you know rich guy
you know it came up in a Porsche
he was like I'm looking for the revolver
that Dirty Harry used Wow
in in the end Dirty Harry I'm like all
right like the one like you know Clint
Eastwood use anyway yeah that's the one
am i all right so Smith & Wesson Model
29 and I hand it to him but we actually
had one they still make him a commercial
production there you go 44 Magnum and he
was like yeah I'll take it didn't wanna
know anything about the gun just wanted
it because it was in Dirty Harry yeah
that's it
so it's just amazing to me that someone
sees it in a video game or something
like oh now I got to have this yeah they
just want especially was again for my
grand theft auto keys driving around
with that yeah yeah on your lap man just
shooting [ __ ] yeah that's just
how it if do you huh have you ever sold
a gun that was used in a crime or murder
I wouldn't know we do get we do get like
police trade in guns and it's not
unheard of for police departments to
have to pick up guns this is all I mean
all around the country they you know
they pick up guns and crimes hmm
and then they that pretty much clear the
crime out but they still have the
firearm with the confiscated off
somebody and then they'll they'll be
sell at the gun stores and the gun
stores are sell it used for cheap price
it's really really popular so there's
plenty of guns out there that have I'm
sure they have some bodies on them like
I got an old I got an old SKS right so
it I've seen it in uh I think in Call of
Duty an SKS I think so I don't know man
it's it was it was a rifle used in the
Vietnam War Lada the one I have was
manufactured in uh in China but it's a
it's a cool rifle and yeah yeah and it's
an awesome rifle it's a first gun I ever
bought man when I turned 18 I bought
that thing and and the one I got was a
was a Vietnam bring back so some veteran
was in Vietnam probably smoked some
Vietnamese dude had an SKS and then took
it home when he came back from the war
hey so who knows what that rifle has
seen you know yeah and I mean the one I
got was made in 1953 so it's a it's
definitely seen something you know there
was some killing years but it's older
than my pops oh yeah man I mean that
thing was probably like you know eerily
early stage of Vietnam War you know and
they were used fighting I mean there's
an originally a Russian gun the gun was
it was invented by a Russian inventor
siminoff but then you know how the
Russians are you know their communist
Union so all of their designs after they
kind of were like declared antiquated
they kind of just spread it around the
you know the the Socialist United world
and so China pretty much got their
manufacturing rights to make these and
the Chinese love them and they made them
in the millions there's millions of
these things around the world right now
you have you have pictures of African
tribes yeah you see a lot of those oh
yeah extended you know earlobes the
whole thing and they don't they're not
even wearing western clothing and they
have an old Chinese SKS over there over
their shoulder that's that's their gun
isn't it interesting like so much of
that uh of the firearms trade that goes
on it's unbelievable I mean whatever you
think is going on commercially in the US
just think under the table
internationally yeah insane I mean you
have countries that you would even
expect like HK in Germany massive
firearms producer they sell they sold I
mean I think like 20,000 g3 rifles to
Saudi Arabia and then all of a sudden
they have they found a bunch of these
rifles it went in the hands of Isis yes
Syria
or they found them in Andy's militia
groups you know al-nusrah in Syria and
they have all these g3 rifles that were
just sent to Saudi Arabia so there's
there's actually like a lot of
international organizations that kind of
track where these where these things
show up I mean those pictures of like
the conflict in Syria the civil war
where they're driving a Panzer 4 from
World War 2 a German tank you know it's
like where the [ __ ] did they get that
that thing weighs 25 tons where the [ __ ]
did they get that yeah they're [ __ ]
Isis driving over Ford Tauruses as well
oh yeah but I'm just saying there's such
a there's such like a secondary market
that well it's so funny like how on the
surface would be like you know no guns
no guns no guns and then if you go and
look at how America makes money but one
of the ways is through selling firearms
to different countries it's crazy
firearms it's a fraction of it if you
think about the military-industrial
complex we're talking weapon systems
I mean fighter jets missiles things that
one single f-35 right lightning to the
pretty much our newest fifth-generation
multi-role jet I mean they're worth
[ __ ] billions of dollars it's just
the whole program itself and and they're
sent them they're sold to all these
countries in NATO and I mean all these
weapons systems just end up in the hands
of all types of people
it's the weapons trade not just small
arms not just riding guns and rice so up
or to even everything-everything
intercontinental ballistic missiles old
submarines ships everything everything
these the defense industry
internationally and even under the table
is [ __ ] monumental monumental do you
think any guns are unnecessary like for
normal people to have or are you just
like I think everybody should have
everything everyone should should be a
right what do you think um yeah that's
tough like you have in certain states
and stuff giving certain licensing which
apparently isn't terribly hard to get
you can get like an old Soviet artillery
gun and there's people private owners
that own tanks with live guns in them 75
millimeter cannons machine guns I don't
think anyone should be barred from
owning those things but I understand the
licensing required to have something
destructive that's what the ATF calls
some things there's destructive devices
quote-unquote and and these firearms I
mean not even firearms but do you have
these you have weapons that are
devastating and I can understand the
logic of like yeah maybe we shouldn't
give you know like inner-city crime
gangs RPGs right right
however I think if you're if you're a
law like a law abiding owner and you can
use those things responsibly I don't
think there should be limitations on
what you can get especially because it's
a slippery slope I mean you can see it
in California right but it did but then
also like imagine if the guy who like
shoots up the Las Vegas you know right
if that guy had an RPG abhi insane yeah
I mean who knows I suppose I mean it
would fire a rocket right I mean he did
he did plenty of damage with a ar-15
anyway well supposedly an ar-15 who
knows I don't know what I don't know
what do you think a lot of a ar-15 so
what they say yeah yeah so I understand
the logic I don't necessarily agree with
it it's kind of tricky it's just really
tricky I don't know how I feel about it
because so in addition to the Beretta
what is the other piece of gun that I
bought you bought an ar-15 lower
receiver yeah so what I mentioned
earlier is that the only the only
[ __ ] bro
Johnny little bastard the only
serialized part of that yeah there you
go that's a that's called a stripped
lower that's what I got so that's
considered a firearm it's a piece of
aluminum with holes in it okay that's a
gun that's a gun right that's considered
a gun so I had to get I had to buy this
piece yeah in order to be able to have
this yeah and the one you the one you
got costed you about 40 bucks and then
now I can build the have the rest of
every all the other parts trigger
internal parts kits trigger group buffer
tube the upper receiver the barrel
everything you need on that gun you can
order it online and have it deliver to
your house giving you have a little bit
of know-how and some simple tools we'll
throw it together for you and you'll
have an area 15 it's not it's not like a
we're gonna do with the nailer 15 oh
okay yeah it's it they're [ __ ] sick
man they're ar-15s are probably the
coolest rifles you can get your hands on
in my opinion in the United States I
mean they're kind of like it's like the
the Ford f-150 of guns you know
everyone's like everyone's got one right
actually in the country but yeah yeah
man they're the most popular rifle in
United States semi-automatic shoots a
very controllable easy easy to use
cartridge ar-fifteens have been used
how many shoots can I do at once and
this with it depends it depends on the
size of the magazine you have inside of
the gun but max swapping a magazine is
not very hard so a standard capacity
magazine throughout the country's 30
rounds this with like the military uses
on their ARS California the limits 10
rounds per magazine but I mean they make
60 round drum magazines 100-round drum
magazines for I'll probably stick with
30 or 60 right well you'll get 10 yeah
I'll do 10 yeah California
um yeah Cal point is yeah you got 10
yeah same thing in your pistol your
pistols supposed to hold what 15 rounds
in the magazine California get to 10
that's the rule that's the rule
ten rounds limit for whatever gun in
California I like that yeah that's thing
if you can't get it done in ten you
deserve to die I think fair enough
I'm saying though like if you a shot you
[ __ ] you know I'm saying you've killed
you you [ __ ] shot the guy's wife you
[ __ ] killed two animals and [ __ ]
blew out your [ __ ] bedroom wall nice
never ducked out every street light on
your block man yeah yeah at that point
you need to go you're really good at
that point is your turn yeah you're the
one really causing the most trouble at
that point right I just don't like it
because I don't like the government
telling me how many rounds they think is
enough right the police officers I need
to follow that rule the military doesn't
have to I'm not gonna go to Nevada you
drive five hours away and then and
they're 200 round belt-fed [ __ ]
machine guns over there you can have
that there
yeah I mean with a machine gun yeah
given the licensing Wow yeah but the
magazine capacity is not limited in most
states I believe California I believe
Massachusetts New York a few other
states have magazine capacity limits
Colorado I think to see honey because I
believe that people I believe that some
semi-automatic weapons people shouldn't
have you know I believe that people
shouldn't be able to just rattle off 700
rounds right but then Here I am buying a
semi-automatic weapon you buy two
semi-automatic weapons ones a ones a
quite capable rifle and the other ones a
very well-loved and well used
semi-automatic
dude not man they there they're cool man
I mean once you won through it once it
all done I'm taking you out and we're
going on the range all right Megan take
you guys to mana be a good time I
doesn't want to [ __ ] shoot somebody
myself dude come on dude you're not
gonna shoot me
well no I got a separate day than feel
oh yeah we'll go next in and we'll leave
Co out there you'll be fine don't worry
do you have a feeling in your life that
you'll ever shoot someone I pray to God
that I [ __ ] don't to have a feeling I
would
I don't really what did you got tell you
what my gut tell me that I might
damn man well I would say oh [ __ ] that's
it Jess tricky given the situation now I
would say it's not terribly unlikely I
knew this old dude and he and he and he
shot some people broke into his house
and he was telling me about it he said
it was [ __ ] terrible but I really
hope I don't want to but now I don't
think I will man I don't think I got I
live in a live in a fairly secure
complex I don't think anyone's the only
situation I see myself doing that is
like someone trying to kill me in my
house and that's pretty unlikely yeah I
don't think so but I mean I like guns
for the I like recreational shooting
like it's one of my favorite hobbies in
the world I go hunting I love it I love
it I shoot archery too it's awesome but
yeah I want to get into some more these
types of things you know that's what I'm
excited to get out to the range I mean I
did notice immediately whenever you
started to teach me even in the store
about how to load the gun unload the gun
like the steps to go through by the end
of that I felt I felt five times more
confident even just picking the gun up
and like I just felt a lot more like
okay now I have some education that goes
along with this thing it's not just a
parent thing that could just kill me at
any moment like now I understand okay
this is how it behaves this is how I
need to use it these are the these are
the protocols I need to go through
exactly it was really interesting to me
just to notice how what immediately when
I had that education yeah it really
adjusted the way that that the gun felt
to me it makes a world of difference
when people talk about accidental
shootings and then how how dangerous
guns can be in the home but
if you if you have the experience and
the knowledge and the know-how and the
confidence to utilize that firearm
confidently there's no chance of it of
it injuring you or anyone else is if you
followed all the proper protocols it's
an inanimate object just like anything
else it's gonna it's gonna hurt you as
much as this glass bottle will it makes
no difference it's just an object the
only thing that gives it the capability
of being lethal is somebody either
making a mistake or someone using it
with Mal intention yes it that's it do
you feel like if as the fear the
pandemic and stuff goes away that you
you'll see a resurgence of people
selling their guns back I think so yeah
I think so I think a lot of people are
just behind them and they don't know
what the hell they're gonna do with them
and I think as soon as they have the
opportunity to get rid of it I think the
use gun market after all this is over is
gonna be booming so and where does the
use gun markets in guns - so guns oh
they'll sell it I mean there's a lot of
forms online where the oh hey I'm
selling this gun we'll do a private
party meet at this gun store they do the
private party and that's it a lot of
times people like hey I just wanna get
her the gun I don't care about finding
someone willing to buy it so they sell
it to gun stores and then the gun store
to resell them for profit have you ever
sold a gun to a guy with like teardrop
tattoos by his iron
yep I have yeah oh yeah yeah I mean hey
if they pass the background check Who am
I to say that they can't own the gun
right well you don't really have that
jurisdiction no I don't well IIIi have I
have the ability to choose who I sell a
gun to I can say no I'm not gonna sell
you gun but I mean I'm not trying to
cause those issues and what I'm not
gonna try to be stuck-up and that and
that kind of ability that kind of
mindset can lead to the people being you
know using that to to pretty much be you
know be racist or something right if
they see someone oh I don't let's say I
don't like I don't like Asian people
right oh I'm not gonna sell any Asian
people a gun that's crazy man right
that's crazy if they're if they have the
ability to buy a gun legally right not
your responsibility
helmet right it's not yeah you're just
working in a place that sells guns yeah
yeah yeah but like you said I mean if
somebody's high you can not sell them a
gun yeah that that comes down but that
just comes down to the law if I if I can
literally smell marijuana I can get in
trouble for selling them or even serving
them or even putting a gun in their
hands if they smell like marijuana which
I think it's crazy but that's just the
rules have you ever had a person who you
liked and you had to ask him like are
you planning on killing somebody
this gun no I never had to do that what
you do it if you felt compelled to do it
oh yeah yeah I'm pretty I'm pretty
outspoken at the store you've blocked
people that are kind of shy that worked
there but yeah I mean I'm you know I
like to crack jokes and stuff it's it's
a gun store man like it Wow seriously
can you take your job you know I'm just
I'm having a good time
I felt way more machismo once I got in
there they got all kind of stuff check
little buckets you could sit on they got
those all type of fishing stuff nets you
could catch stuff they had gloves for
all type of different things you could
do it gloves all I mean we have a whole
fishing lesson although it was good it's
the fun stuff yeah you ever been a Bass
Pro Shop um yeah that's the [ __ ]
that's his knuckle right there man
that's a [ __ ] play the news yeah
they're real nice you do whatever you
want there fellas I'm good
talk under Johnny no I just have one
more it might be a crazy question has
anyone ever tried to rob your store or
have you ever heard of anyone trying to
rob a gun store I've asked I've asked
that question my manager and apparently
our location was robbed a long long time
ago dude is just like there's a lot of
gun stores especially more like family
and not family-oriented but like smaller
businesses were the people in there are
armed and most of those places don't get
hit Turner's is a corporation and do - I
guess insurance purposes they don't want
us to be armed so that we're not armed
in the store I was gonna be my last
question yeah well we're not we're not
armed in the store at all over there
so could you reach for an arm though we
can get a gun but I mean we don't have
loaded magazines or ammunition on us nor
would we terribly be inclined to
retaliate considering if someone's in
there ready to rob a gun store they
probably don't give a [ __ ] and they
probably got guns ready to rock and roll
so if we're not if we're in a position
where we're already I had a deficit just
due to the fact that we don't have
loaded weapons on us i retaliation is
probably not the best idea what would
you do then run right the [ __ ] out of
there why would someone rob a gun store
for a gun if they have a gun well they
get well they they have a gun but then
they can just go in there and steal a
hundred guns we're gone yeah they
[ __ ] breaking the glass and they
stiff they steal a bunch of guns then
[ __ ] man they I mean that's a lot of
money is there a method of that micro
stamping you think that could be could
work because
it does seem a little bit archaic when
you think about it that you have this
gun you have this bullet that they that
there isn't a way to definitely track
and know what's going on you know just
because we have so much technology now
right I can I can see micro stamping
maybe working and the way where you will
be you'll have the ability to track the
gun
however practically speaking that would
it would significantly increase the
price of the firearm okay
and it's very easily worked around I
mean you I mean it's really easy to
scratch out the serial number of a gun
right it's really easy to scratch out a
mic like something like a micro stamping
just right yeah it says that the
stamping wears out that it's not it just
wears out what youth right well now even
if I intentionally try to get rid of it
or if I just replace the part that has
the microstamping on it right by a
replacement firing gun yeah I'm just
wondering what the you know what the
technology is that will allow you to
yeah that will solve the problem you
know yeah Micra sent me seems like it's
like an attempt at that yeah I'm just
trying to just think do you feel like
everyone should be able to own a gun
yeah unless you're mentally incompetent
or a hardened criminal I would say yes I
would say yeah everyone should have the
ability to unless you're I mean just
completely irresponsible yeah I mean
it's it's I don't necessarily see it as
a right that that's given to us it's a
right that a human being should have
inherently I'm not a religious people
religious guy people say like oh these
right these rights are god-given right
I'm not really just at all but I feel
like you know I believe people got about
a gun really yeah I feel like people
should have inherent rights man like if
you're just a human being you have the
you know your freedom of speech you're
allowed to express yourself right right
you're allowed to vote politically
you're allowed to you know not be
enslaved right you're just a free human
being you should be able to have a tool
to protect your life and the life of
people around you yeah so I think if
unless you're completely mentally
incompetent or or a hardened dangerous
criminal then yeah everyone should have
the right to own a gun we have a world
so we have a world that has guns in it
do you wish that we had
world there's somebody who just never
invented guns and since I like gun so
much no yeah however admittingly
things would be I would say less lethal
if if there was no guns but for a much
longer period than guns have ever
existed
there's still been massive war and
conflict coming out to the class square
how people love killing each other
exactly doesn't matter you got a gun or
not it doesn't matter
I mean people I mean they would ride
horses with you know Lance's on them and
go and stab people to death yeah
thousands would die in single battles it
doesn't it doesn't make a difference
yet people love to kill each other they
have I mean even the mayor of Baltimore
announced that had to ask people to stop
killing each other so they could save
the hospitals for kovat patients for
Corbin complete pleat please stop
shooting yeah that's really what he said
so yeah people love to yeah baltimore
mayor begs residents to stop shooting
each other so hospital beds can be used
for coronavirus patients so i mean
that's real [ __ ] i also think it was who
came out i think it was the mayor of
dallas he was saying that uh Oh like
like criminals like chill criminals take
it easy because like like we all just
want to go home at the end of the day so
just relax for now I thought it was
pretty ridiculous yeah just take a break
criminals actually before this I was
having Easter uh brunch with a friend of
mine his stepfather is a a California
Highway patrolman he's been at this for
like 30 years
Brendan's stepdad actually and he was
telling me that crime is down except for
auto theft auto theft is the only crime
that's up that makes sense a lot more
cars parked now yeah yeah ready to go
make it if your burglar you got to do
something you still got to work and you
do car now you don't know money manager
if you're if you live in that life you
got there yeah man it was interesting
yeah I just found it so interesting Nico
that I cuz I came in and you just knew
so much about weapons and and I was like
man this is kind of fascinating and I
was kind of I was like everything I was
excited to be buying a gun I was scared
to be buying a gun kind of yeah I was
kind of glad I finally felt like at
least confident and adult enough within
myself to be like okay I can have a gun
in my house and I'm not gonna shoot a
buddy or something funny do anything
crazy kid um so yeah and then you said
man there's just so many people buying
guns right now in the face
interesting to me you know in a state
that you know a lot of times you're a
lot of people like no guns no guns and
then this type of we get into this core
of it and everybody's gone and out oh oh
yeah I mean just just the numbers
they're mind-blowing just the numbers of
mine blown there's gonna be a lot more
guns out there yeah okay ready for it
bottom line bottom line do you sell a
lot of Kevlar and stuff like that with
them or often or no now we don't sell
any body armor there we do have like
some plate carriers that we sell there
that allow you to insert like plate
armor oh you got inside of the vest but
we're not we're not an Armour retailer I
don't really know if that's up for
private sale in California I'm not not
entirely sure but and what about flares
nades anything like that yeah I mean I
wish we sold grenades man that'd be sick
but now we don't explosive not gonna
happen that would be sweet though man we
actually talked about grenades when you
came in I remember that that's pretty
funny
oh yeah we did no no no no flares all
yeah grenades grenades are cool man I
was in I was in Cambodia and also my my
cousin you could run a [ __ ] grenade
over there about yeah yeah they had like
they were advertising man we're in this
little we're in this little tiny little
tiny village called Koh Kong it's on
this river by the Thai border and they
were there and there and there you guys
were asking us like oh yeah but they saw
our backpacks I'm got like
military-style backpacks you know where
no one's in the military room with but
they were like oh yeah you like guns you
like guns and we're like yeah yeah we
like guns and they're like you go like
come on we have machine gun we have RPG
and like let's go shoot and we didn't
end up doing it I kind of regret that I
kind of wish I kind of wish that we did
but they're like oh yeah you can throw
grenades and everything damn yeah can't
do Cambodia had a massive you know
genocide at a civil war is gone yes it's
decision yeah yeah they got everywhere
yeah there's krembos will [ __ ] shoot
anything dude bro you pull up a grenade
detonation on YouTube people are shocked
always when they see this think people
think needs go big they really don't go
that big you know a basic nade don't
really [ __ ] do that much yeah we were
just talking about that man it's just
it's just really it's just really a pot
man like well people see grenades and
movies you know they see an action movie
they throw a grenade it's a giant
fireball man it just blows up but uh
it's really a pretty small amount of
explosives not that one not that one no
one takes too long
but I've watched out before there
they're not they're not terrible they're
not terribly lethal I mean well they're
not they're very lethal but they're not
like massive explosions and grenade
compilation okay let's try that
that's um Kurdistan [ __ ] look at that
yeah and then you gotta throw further
nothing to do three four feet what a
freak there's Cambodia for you we had to
run back you know it used to be eight
seconds on the grenade I believe now
it's four seconds oh yeah because people
we have is it was too much time early we
don't wanna say we don't like a French
war or something they were throwing back
huh yeah yeah that's so interesting how
they could make it you know like a time
like that how do they even build that I
don't it doesn't I don't understand yeah
it is really interesting what you pull
that pin the firt of the the first like
well like really widespread means
grenades here's a guy white dude using
it sorry interrupt a good man set Danny
McBride that's what I would rather
popping Cambodian I got through a
left-handed he's obviously well look how
small bit is it's really smaller than
you think
yeah I mean that is just a little blip
yeah but in terms of the timing like the
first grenades that really used widely
were with in World War one man it was
called the mills bomb but the British
used them and they had an internal fuse
that would kind of burn inside the
grenade and now it'll make it go off so
you'd you would pull the pin a safety
pin and then you'd throw it and there's
like a little hinge that's almost been a
tease what is it called let's look at uh
Mills bomb Mills bomb yeah it was like
the first like widely used grenade in
combat I mean there was earlier examples
of like more primitive grenades but the
first like widely produced and and you
know issued grenade in World War one
Wow look at that yeah Mills bomb that's
that old-school hitter day
oh yeah a 36 meter Mills bomb right
there there and so then all those pieces
would so how does this one work yeah so
there's there's you'd pull that pin and
then there's actually a little striker
after you pull the pin and you let go of
the grenade and that would allow like a
spring-loaded striker to hit a fuse and
that fuse would burn for I mean
approximately I think five seconds and
and after that it would just go off
there's a little bit of high explosive
in there and then pretty much you how
they cut those shapes into the the
actual body of the grenade the explosive
power would break the grenade fragments
on those cuts and that would be your
fragmentation early grenades were you
were really used more for for taking
enemy positions than they were for for
really like outright killing them so
they would throw them they weren't
terribly lethal in terms of
fragmentation they would just throw them
especially inside of bunkers and what
were one down in the trenches everyone
would be dazed and confused because of
the grenade that went off blowing
everyone's ears out and making them
blind and they would run in there with
bayonets and and really finish the job
that was really how it was done back in
the day nade city dog so I'm telling you
guys keep your [ __ ] together though
y'all get nade it out and and World War
one man they had like German
stormtroopers when they're attack enemy
trenches oh yeah lot of times they
wouldn't even go in with a rifle when
they were talking in a position they had
these giant sacks that they would tie up
to their shoulders and they would you be
full grenades they would have 12
grenades on them and then like a club so
they would go in there at night raiding
trenches throw 12 grenades and then
after all the grenades go off they will
run in there with a club and start
beating people to death yeah it was
crazy crazy man it sounds like that
movie Black Hawk Down no she's like no
here no Delilah Black Swan no black with
the big fish in San Diego it's that cold
black fish like 50 black fish
nikka man thanks so much any more
questions guys I think that's it yeah
man it looks like we're in a we're just
hit we're in a new we're in an
environment where a lot of people are
getting armed yeah amen if you firearms
man they're a good way to go it's a
great hobby it's a great way to protect
your life man and as long as you use
them faithfully there
really just a lot of fun so do you think
I could be a safe user of firearms I
wouldn't sell it to you if I didn't
think you wouldn't know my Thomas to be
perfectly honest with you my cool
respect thanks dude I appreciate that
good to know I can do that and all right
thank you so much for being here man I
appreciate it man yeah of course there
thank you guys for having me yeah you
bet oh wait one more thing I want to ask
you about yeah so there was a video you
were showing me of uh what other type of
um like hunting and outdoor activities
you like to do all right well here and
here in LA man I do a lot of uh I mean
this even just ended but I do a lot of
scuba diving and this time I'm really
into so my cousin and I and my aunt and
my dad and my uncle will go out so we
got a lot of scuba gear and we'll go
down and in different spots around like
pretty much the west side out in the
ocean and we go either out in a little
boat or we go out there late at night
you know kind of Navy SEAL style and we
go there and pick out Lobster so we go
out there with lobster bag we wear
Kevlar gloves flashlights and and you're
there and they come out at night to feed
and then where you at where you located
at here right now when you do it know
when you do this
Oh palos verdes around the marina
Redondo up in Malibu just too much the
whole Bay obey and then you go out there
late at night and underwater it's
completely pitch black down there so all
the lobsters o'clock coming out and we
have bright flashlights we're all you
know fully scoop it out so we're about
you know 30 40 feet underwater by the
rocks even sometimes even shallower and
then you grabs you grab these big bugs
man and they're trying to fight you and
they start grabbing and kicking and then
you stuff him in a bag and you fill up
the bag you know the limits seven per
day so we'll fill them up and then bring
it back up and we have we have some good
cookouts we also go like I do a little
bit of fishing out in like a few rivers
we go crawfishing it's a lot of fun so
it's similar to lobster you get a lot
more of them and they're smaller and oh
yeah and then and then yeah other than
that do hunting and that's a lot of fun
mostly birds but do some deer hunting
too it's a lot of fun then lobstering so
interesting man dude it'll out there at
night
oh yeah it's pitch [ __ ] dark dude the
first time I did it I was freaking out
all sigh damn you're and you're and
you're down there with these ancient
[ __ ] crustaceans these things have
been on this planet
way longer than we have yeah you know
and they're not used to [ __ ]
going down there with scuba tanks and a
brand a thousand lumen flashlight and
they said they'd freak out and they you
grab them up and you put them in a bag
man okay do you use a weapon or anything
you just grab with your hands grab with
your hands man Kevlar gloves you just
grab
here there California spiny lobster so
they don't have claws like you'd like
they do on the East Coast they just
covered in spikes if you grab them with
just your hand no they'll cut you Odie's
so you got with a Kevlar glove so you
stuff him in a bag [ __ ] yeah and they'll
squeeze onto your hand real tight
they're actually surprisingly pretty
strong but and if you get a big one you
know you got to go two hands so you grab
two hands and you have to pretty much
hold it onto your chest because they're
trying to kick away from you like a baby
Elmo yeah and then your dive buddy
pretty much too common like help him get
it off and get into the bag and it's
crazy man you get if you get if you land
a big feeling a big lobster man it's it
is [ __ ] wild it's a lot of food there
man so I've got a lot of options here
sounds good huh oh yeah and then you
cook I'm not cooking my Lobby style I
throw them on the grill just butter and
seasoning man it's [ __ ] good good
Gianni's little soft ass out there to
catch one or add one even if you got to
down out down to come out in cold water
man yeah we got some Lobster I guess I'm
trying to get them rod a lobster oh hell
yeah well in that diving man I mean no
it was diving in the Philippines it's
all whale shark I mean I did another
dive around a bunch of sardines so I
love diving match another that's another
like big hobby of mine and I love love
scuba diving yeah I got to get more of
that outdoor motif going on I used to
have when I was young because we spend
so much time outdoors but you know the
city will really change you oh yeah I
mean hey kind of kind killed you felt a
little bit yeah definitely well now and
kill other people's souls cuz I have two
[ __ ] guns
[ __ ] take souls while you lose yours
bro Nikko thanks so much for coming by
Thanks
[Music]
it's gonna take
grey bully no so pretty much polymer 80
is pretty much a copy of a Glock maybe
we start off with a piece off of the
metal frame just like the same color as
that barrel okay and it's just pretty
much just a straight block and we do all
these machine cuts we make our own
compensator yeah ordered that do that do
that cut for the site so you can
actually aim and you can pick up that
red dot so you guys can check that up
yeah you want the dot where you just put
the down wherever and then wherever you
did out it you're gonna that's where you
boy be getting a sight like a little
[ __ ] Tinker Bell on that [ __ ] dog
are you gonna say yes that's a custom
piece that we did man so I did all the I
did all the internal work on it so
that's it yeah so that's my competition
piece I want to shoot this a competition
that's what I mean how much does that
cost to get up yeah he was firing a gun
[ __ ] studio are you
she got you up yo yeah there you go it's
crazy - man once you learn like how it
all works so show us how to open it up
and Center so this just like your
beretta man this your side release
talking about yeah so 20 rounds in here
its foot California and so you pretty
much have a few controls in this comes
really really simple there's your
magazine release so the magazines in
there press that button tough the night
oh damn just like that oh damn pull back
on the side you can just pull that and
grab the red light whatever you like and
if you want to hold it with no magazine
you push up on that alright the rear
it'll lock it or use the magazine
follower in there pull back on the slide
and I'll lock it up for you and then you
can just press down on that piece just
like that dude you gotta join a gang
right pivotal in that [ __ ] okay so I
would take this out and then you want to
clear it so you push up on that and then
fly to the rear all right there you go
over that there you go all right how to
drop it you press down on that often and
this is all custom yeah it's a it's a
cuff it's a custom frame and then we get
a blank slide and we order it all in and
then I do all the internal like
polishing work and then we do the
machine cuts here and we do custom we do
seracote all in-house we do that color
when it's your beretta we can do that we
can do whatever pattern you want crazy
[ __ ] decked up
we can have we can have [ __ ] you know
do monogram on the [ __ ] whatever you
want all right P yeah whatever you like
dude
whatever you like Billy comport ya Billy
comport Oh special all right Billy
that's a great idea
now do these come custom keep these
custom done as well now these are some
normal Glock magazines here is an
extended base plate so you place the you
replaced of the actual base plate of the
magazine add this metal base plate on
there and that adds you three more round
to the capacity Oh God
the possession of actually more than ten
round capacity magazines in California
is not illegal
so the possession of them is not illegal
bringing them from another state or
binding them here or selling them here
is illegal but having a
Coffee magnate California is not illegal
yeah yeah it makes you so much harder
all the [ __ ] guns are sold out online
everywhere because the California
compliant ones are so different than
than everyone else we have to have Cal
for supplying versions or your or your
[ __ ] like 90% of the guns online we're
all sold out everywhere that's crazy
good
yeah man that's cool cool stuff dude I
appreciate you guys appreciate you guys
having me on man a lot of fun